zu Beginn dieses Videos hören wir uns
den Prolog der Daniela Katzenberger an
ich liebe die Weihnachtszeit über alles
Plätzchen backen das ganze Haus
schmücken bis es in jeder Ecke funkelt
und glitzert schlimm und es sich mit den
Liebsten so richtig gemütlich machen mit
meinem Adventskalender möchte ich Dir
deshalb den Dezember verzaubern und die
die Tage bis zum Fest versüßen 24
Überraschungen zum snacken Kochen und
Backen erwarten dich und dazu einige
tolle Beauty und Lifestyle Produkte eben
alles für eine wundervolle Adventszeit
das klingt doch toll damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackvideo heute
testen wir den Adventskalender von
Daniela Katzenberger und das schon im
zweiten darauf folgenden Jahr jeder auf
dieser Welt hat gefühlt mittlerweile
seinen eigenen Adventskalender außer
diese Person
nein Spaß es wäre mir viel zu viel
Arbeit das macht Spaß das werden wir
nicht viel zu viel Arbeit keiner hat
Interesse an mir ich weiß nicht wie
diese ganzen Influenza und und Promis
Adventskalender rausbringen wie ich
wüsste nicht mal wen ich dazu fragen
sollte Adventskalender
GmbH gibt's sowas weiß ich nicht bevor
wir diesen Adventskalender auspacken
muss ich erstmal ein Gerücht aus der
Welt schaffen und zwar dass der Kalender
von ihr letztes Jahr blöd war in Touch
hat geschrieben dass der gar nicht so
gut war weil irgendeine influencerin
Youtuberin oder sonst werden bewertet
hat und schlecht bewertet hat das Ding
ist aber an der Sache dass sie mein Foto
dafür verwendet haben wir haben von
einer anderen Person gesprochen und mein
Foto verwendet und das ist in der
InTouch gelandet also Daniela
Katzenberger falls du das hier siehst
ich fand den okay er ist super es ist
ein super Adventskalender aber was
dieses Jahr ist sehen wir jetzt bevor
ihr denkt dass ich mit Daniela
Katzenberger unter einer Decke stecke
und mir hier die Taschen heimlich voll
mache dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
und jetzt alle dieses Videos nicht
der Preis des Kalenders liegt bei 69
Euro 99 finde ich schon sehr doll den
kann man auf Katzenberger geschenke.de
kriegen aber er wird eigentlich von
foodist vertrieben also ich weiß nicht
ganz genau wie sie das da geregelt haben
es ist quasi ein gutes Adventskalender
mit dem Daniela Katzenberger Logo Fotos
ist ja auch so eine also foodles haben
auch übelst viele Adventskalender keine
Ahnung warum die noch nicht gefragt
haben der Warenwert liegt bei 214 €.
gucken wir mal ob das stimmt und es sind
limitierte und überrannten neue Snacks
dabei und original Produktgrößen fangen
wir mal mit dem äußer waren also optisch
finde ich ihn cute es ist aber nicht
mein Geschmack ich bin halt nicht dieses
pinke Gold mit so ne das ist halt nicht
mein Ding aber es ist ja weihnachtlich
gestaltet das ist ja immer schön und wir
preche jetzt natürlich wieder
verwendbare Kalender ihr seid ganz live
mit dabei ganz nah dran Türchen Nummer
eins endlich Nummer eins befindet sich
[Musik]
nothing but seaside weißt du die Mandeln
Cashews und Erdnüsse ist eine
Originalgröße ist doch keine
Originalgröße unter den Türchen steht
auch immer so ein Text let it Sparkle
pinkes Lametta und glitzerkugeln sind
meine Liebste Weihnachtsdeko und
verbreiten festliche Stimmung im ganzen
Haus wahrscheinlich gibt es unter jeder
Box so einen kleinen Gruß von Daniela
Katzenberger finde ich aber toll weil
das macht irgendwie persönlicher man ist
ja dann Daniela Katzenberger Fan wenn
man sich diesen Adventskalender holt und
dann hat man hier kleine weihnachtstipps
von ihr 214 €. obwohl Nüsse sind teuer
haha haha
okay ich kann Schlüssel bei Amazon
kaufen bei Amazon gibt's die für
1,45€, das Stück
aber ihr liebt es wenn ich die Preise
nach checke ich denke die haben jetzt
hier nicht das Rad neu erfunden und ich
weiß wie Nüsse schmecken deswegen kommt
das in die verlosungsbox weiter geht's
mit Tüte Nummer zwei mein Tipp für eine
entspannte Weihnachtszeit wenn die ab
und zu mal ein schönes Schaumbad also
bei den Preisen zur Zeit für das ein
teures Schaumbad oh Liquid matt lips oh
Matte Lippen ich wollte einen Lipgloss
von Gosch ihr müsst reflektiert hier zu
doll aber Gosch Kopenhagen bei gut
Douglas kann man das kaufen aha die
Farbe ist schön ist ein Barry Ton und
der kostet 10 € 10
diese Tipps können einfach dazu deswegen
muss man sie auch mit Vorlesen mein
absoluter lieblings-weihnachtssong auf
jeden Fall Jingle Bells was ist mein
lieblings Weihnachtsbaum
nee am driving home for Christmas
[Musik]
ah Nummer 3 hat ein Keks aufstecher
ich sag euch ehrlich wie es ist 50 Cent
diese von der Qualität normal also jetzt
hier nicht besonders gut und nicht
besonders scheiße also völlig
ausreichend Türchen Nummer vier am
dreaming of the pink Christmas hallo
[Musik]
pink Christmas
win bei wisst ihr womit ich gerade
Probleme habe trocknet organic veganen
gluten free das ist ja ein tolles
Produkt ich kenne die Katze jetzt auch
nicht so sehr ne aber das ist für mich
irgendwie nicht so ein Daniela
Katzenberger Produkt ich denke sehr in
Klischees wie schmeckt oh Schokolade
egal wie gut diese organic wiegen
glutenfreak Cookies für einen sind ne
Geschmack her kommen die einfach nicht
an die fresh Produkte dran warum ist der
Schokokeks so viel teurer als die
anderen bei Fotos kostet der 1,59 € das
hier ist ein richtiges Suchspiel mein
Auge kann überhaupt nichts erkennen fünf
ja muss ihre Message
was jeden Tag kriegen wir hier so einen
kleinen frechen Spruch und jetzt sind da
nur Nüsse drauf
einfallen doch 24 Sätze ein die man da
so drunter schreiben kann oder nicht
Gemüse Chips
Chips Tomate und Basel 30 Prozent lässt
Fett für ganzen veganen Bio Sachen so es
ist immer irgendwie ich habe das Gefühl
ich esse schon zum 100 mal Humus Chips
oh die schmecken besonders lecker
Tomaten und Basilikum mega geil gewürzt
Humus Chips kennt ihr diese große Tüte
das ist die gleiche Marke das habt Ihr
Logo verändert das sieht sehr hübsch aus
100 Gramm 22 Euro ja 50 Cent alles klar
wir sind bei Türchen Nummer 6 ihr wisst
es das ist Nikolaus und wir hoffen dass
wir ein nein da kriegen wir schon wieder
nichts fröhlichen Nikolaus mach dir
einen schönen Tag was hattest du im
Stiefel irgendwas
Maiskörner und Food ist Eigenmarke
Maiskörner gerösteten gesalzen das sind
die die man so wunderbar auch ja die war
jetzt nicht auf ich weiß wie die
schmecken das können wir doch gleich
mal bei buchen sag mal so 70 Cent hier
für die Tüte pi mal Daumen was man
schlechtes nikolaus-tücher so wenn jetzt
im nächsten kein Spruch für mich drin
ist ne 7 und hier haben wir auch wieder
einen Spruch mein Tipp für einen schönen
Dezember nicht nur Weihnachtsmusik hören
sonst wirst du irgendwann kirre das
stimmt oh oh
zum Glück habe ich dieser kein Jobs
beides Adventskalender bestellt hier
haben wir ein du hast weißes Gewürz
Hackfleisch gewürzt
so meine so wir haben hier so ein Quinoa
Bike und Hackfleisch Gewürz das eine ist
so Maddie Morrison das andere ist so
sturmwaffel was kostet denn das
hackfleischgewürz 5 € 5
teuer gut man muss aber auch sagen
Charaktere sind ja vielschichtiger als
entweder bist du Fleischfresser oder
Quinoa Fresser so deswegen nehme ich die
Aussage noch mal zurück das passt
zusammen Nummer Nacht mein liebstes
Getränk in der Weihnachtszeit es ist ein
kleines Interview hier Kakao mit vielen
bunten Marshmallows
#coasy Christmas ehrlich hier haben die
was rein gestopft das ist richtig voll
cool Tattoo Vater Trüffel Pesto würde
ich jetzt nicht aufmachen aber uns geil
ist es geil ne Alter geil unnor
mal geil so eine schöne nud
ELN Euro 50 kostet das bei so einem
Spruch wäre das doch nicht cool wenn sie
dann halt auch bunte Marshmallows dann
in diesem Ding drin hätte dann hätte das
ja voll so auf Produkte anpassen kannst
meine Lieblingszahl meine lieblingszeit
in der Nummer 9
ich hätte vielleicht hier was wieder
zurück reinpacken sollen ich sehe es
jetzt auch aber meistens haben die immer
so diese Zwischenböden dass man das
nicht mehr machen muss aber gut hier
schon kommen wir zum 9 Türchen und ihr
wisst aus dem Playmobil Adventskalender
das ist neunte Türchen immer das beste
ist natürlich ist im neuen Türchen ist
ein Backofen drin weil ich so gerne
backe Weihnachten bei den Katzenbergers
wir machen es uns gerne im Schlabberlook
auf der Couch bequem und schauen
Weihnachtsfilme am liebsten im
festlichen onesie Sam sister same ah ja
ich weiß nicht ob es bei dieser Creme
nicht gut läuft ich packe in der Nähe
schon paar Jahre aus und ich habe das
Gefühl die ist jedes Jahr irgendwo mit
dabei oder es ist fantastisches
Marketing es funktioniert so gut dass
sie es jedes Mal wieder machen eine
Augencreme 10 ml
ein Liter von dieser Creme kostet
11.200 €, nee das muss ein Fehler sein
das sind 10 ml bei look fantastic sollen
diese 10 ml 110 € Kosten das das muss
ein Fehler sein das ist kein Fehler bei
Parfumdreams kostet sie 84 € würde es
einfach mal 90 € sagen zehn Milliliter
was ist das für eine Creme warum ist die
überall drin warum ist die so teuer boah
ich bin schockiert schockiert und das
war eine Nummer 9 drin weil die Nummer 9
das beste Türchen ist 10 in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei darf bei mir niemals
Buttergebäck fehl das ist in meiner
Familie schon seit mehreren Generationen
Tradition und ich kann nie genug davon
bekommen
snackbites schmecken wie Cookie Dough
der Milch drin keine Milch
ja gut dann nicht
weil sie was für eine Kindersicherung
das sein soll aber dann machen wir es
halt so also sieht das aus wie auf der
Packung ja doch schon cookidoo
nein Leute
Energie Riegel mit Datteln aber schlecht
sind sie nicht 2,90 € und Kinder nach
der 10 kommt die 11 und kein Spruch von
Katzenberger dafür aber Battle baking
Pancake Backmischung mit Hafer
Buchweizen und Zimt oh die könnten
lecker sein vegan glutenfrei mit
kokosblütenzucker wir lieben gute Siegel
Bio-Siegel ist hier für die Zubereitung
gibt es hier einen vegan und ein
traditionellen Vorschlag zwei Euro und
die mache ich mir vielleicht morgen wir
sind jetzt erst bei der Hälfte
angekommen ich habe das Gefühl ich packe
diesen Adventskalender schon seit zehn
Jahren aus kein Spruch
das passt doch Arsch auf einmal hier
Candy kittens vegane palmölfreie
Gummibärchen oder wenn ich jetzt aber
gespannt wie die schmecken wild
strawberry ja vegane Gummibärchen und so
ein Zeug ist immer schwierig ne obwohl
die von Katjes schon echt die geilsten
sind auch von Katis ein Adventskalender
irgendwie ja soll ich den mal
ausprobieren schreibt's gerne in die
Kommentare ja die sehen schon mega süß
aus
oh die schmeckt mir richtig gut
voll die sind so lecker kennen die
kittens also die kommen aus London 80
Cent 13
Adventskalender bricht zusammen und da
haben wir wieder einen Spruch mein
lieblings Weihnachtsfilm drei Haselnüsse
für Aschenbrödel der passt doch
fantastisch Cookie Cat dann haben Sie
nicht nur so katzenprodukte gefunden das
wäre so cool gewesen wenn alles
irgendwie Katze wäre Make-up für Cat eye
machen Katzen Gummis ja okay sorry aber
das ist das gleiche das könnt ihr mir
nicht erzählen das ist so gleich dass
ich dir nicht mal probieren muss weil
ich mir ganz genau vorstellen kann wie
der schmeckt
Cookie Cat Bio 1,50 € kostet der Keks
das nehmen wir ist notiert Nummer 14 uh
wir lieben ethisch und fairly traded
Schokolade wie ein Franklin offizielle
vegan Zeichen karamellisierte Haselnuss
und hafermilchschokolade oh sieht krass
aus ich weiß nicht was mit ihr passiert
ist aber die hat teilweise an manchen
Stellen doch so alterungserscheinung
hat sie ganz schön seht ihr das so am
Rand
[Musik]
ich meine es ist auch wirklich wie keine
Lindt Schokolade aber die ist lecker die
ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker ich habe
schon so viele vegane Schokoladen
probiert bei vielen schmeckst du einfach
diese milchalternative raus und so die
ist yummy well und truly was kostest du
2,99 €. nach der 14 kommt die 15 und
jetzt ist mein Tipp für das
Weihnachtsmenü an den Feiertagen lieber
nicht zu komplizierter Rezepte Kochen es
soll schließlich eine schöne und
entspannte Zeit mit der Familie sein
hauptsache lecker und das ist ein
schöner Tipp
ohohohoho werden wir verwöhnt
zu viel Rosenburg lash Style Curler der
sieht ja massiv aus und hübsch ich habe
heute noch versucht so ein tiktok
Make-up Tipp zu machen wo man dann
dieses Ding hier drauf legt und den
Lidschatten so darüber macht dass man
dann so hier dunkel hat und hier hält
aber meine hat so einen komische Kurve
und der ist jetzt so genau wie ich ihn
brauche der kommt wie gerufen doch 14 €,
32 16 groß ab und zu mal einen Becher
Glühwein trinken hilft gegen den
Weihnachtsstress und bringt dich in
festliche Stimmung Weihnachten soll doch
so eine schöne besinnliche Zeit sein
aber alle reden immer nur über den
Weihnachtsstress Ruf natürliches Topping
oh das war eigentlich eine geile Idee
hier hinten ist so ein Bild von dem
Google Home und man macht ja eigentlich
immer so diese ganzen bunten künstlichen
streuselwall drauf aber das mal was
natürliches ist der Kilopreis ist 50 €.
wir machen 1 € 17 welche Weisheit hast
du heute für mich große Katzenberger
wenn Weihnachten zu stressig wird streu
Glitzer drauf
und es Luxus Cocktail elegant süße Nüsse
und die schmecken bestimmt aber gut gut
die haben eigentlich ein tolles Glas 2 €
für luxuslüsse muss man auch mal 2 €
ausgeben Nummer 18 pinke Schokolade was
kann das sein
Daniela Katzenberger hat ihre eigene
Schokolade
okay kommen wir noch mal zu meinem
Argument am Anfang als ich euch gesagt
habe hier sturmwaffelnüsse blablabla ne
ich glaube das hat damit nichts zu tun
das ist ja cool und so das in ihrem
Kalender dann vegane Schokolade drin ist
vegane Gummis veganes und dann bringt
sie aber ihre eigene Schokolade raus
also das ist jetzt die Daniela
Katzenberger Schokolade und in der ist
Vollmilchpulver drin also möchte sie
jetzt vegane Sachen also wisst ihr was
ich meine die ist auf jeden Fall die
sieht sehr süß aus jetzt ist die Frage
das gibt für mich Kindheit vibes so
richtig schöne Aldi Schokolade ich bin
jetzt echt gespannt wie die schmeckt
also ja das das ist irgendwie nur
Verpackung ne
ich bin so verwirrt ich kann gar nicht
sprechen ich glaube die Schokolade
schmeckt okay das ist zwar eine
Katzenberger Schokolade aber sie wurde
von Sweet Kultur hergestellt die Stellen
auch schokoladengeschenke her also wenn
du personalisierte Schokoladen haben
möchtest dann haben Sie hier dieses
Standard Ding ne das ist die Schokolade
mit der Folie und dann verpacken sie es
halt in Katzenberger oder sonst was für
eine Verpackung
nein nicht 50 Cent Nummer 19 von fact an
den Feiertagen gibt es bei mir ganz
klassisch Pute mit Rotkohl und Klößen
#team frescode hat sie nicht gesagt dass
man unkomplizierte Sachen machen sollen
um nicht
ja gut man backt einmal Plätzchen und
dann hat man für 365 Tage wieder keinen
Bock drauf funktioniert das nicht so
wenn wir hier wieder ein klassischen
50er Cent 20 Weihnachten bei den
Katzenbergers bedeutet fresstage statt
Festtage lavera endless Lashes Mascara
mit pflanzlichen Kreatin haben wir hier
wieder schön Bio das ist meine or
online-größe du 14 Euro 69 und jetzt
sind wir mittendrin in den 20ern 21 oh
ich muss mal hier mein ganzer scheiß
bekommen oh heilige Katzenberger gib uns
deine Weisheit Schein bright like a
Christmas tree oh haben wir hier wieder
ein vegan glutenfrei und ein chocolate
chip Nummer drei aber der verbirgt sich
ein bisschen es ist im Endeffekt das
gleiche aber es ist einfach Nummer drei
der kaum es ist ein Einzel ich finde es
nicht aber in 51 Nummer 22
immun direkt sofort Spray was werden wir
denn hier plötzlich so medizinisch
immunformel mit Pflanzenextrakten
Mikronährstoff natürliches Immunabwehr
auch für unterwegs direkt und schneller
Aufnahme über die mundschleiert vier
Sprühstöße eine Anwendung pro Tag direkt
in den Mund springen
das passt ja mal super rein ne ich meine
das ist Winterzeit ne man muss sein
Immunsystem stärken da D3 dabei ja
Vitamin D3 toll 6,95 € haben wir sieben
unser vorletztes Türchen Türchen Nummer
23 oh Junge bin ich gespannt
Bananenchips die kenne ich schon also
nicht die Marke aber Banane Chips sind
jetzt nicht probieren und ich habe
ehrlich gesagt so ekligen Geschmack von
diesem immunspray und wenig Zucker viele
Ballaststoffe
ein Kilo kosten 30 1 €. so Leute hier
sind Chaos hier sind ganz schön viel rum
aber es ist das 24 Türchen wir haben
richtig Lust auf Weihnachten und wir
bekommen eine letzte Botschaft von
Daniela Katzenberger merry christmas ich
wünsche dir einen traumhaftes
Weihnachtsfest in einem kunterbunten
glitzernden Tannenbaum tollen Geschenken
ganz viel leckerem Essen und vor allem
wunderschönen Stunden mit deinen
Liebsten deine Dani
Zeiten miracle Make-up Remover Roman
weil an Weihnachten hat man Make-up
drauf also das ganze Make-up was man
halt hier in diesem Adventskalender
hatte also das das sind die Lifestyle
Produkte
Lifestyle Produkt gucken wir jemand der
lavera kostet
4,87 €, also 4 € irgendwas für diesen
Make-up Remover ja ist halt ein
Preis ich würde sagen wir mal zum großen
zusammenzählen
also ohne diese teure 90 € Augencreme
die ich einfach nicht verstehe sind wir
bei 82 Euro wenn wir dann diese 90 €
teure Augencreme dazu nehmen sind wir
bei 172 € und es wurde geschrieben dass
über 214 € Warenwert ist und es wurde
geschrieben dass es original
Produktgrößen sind also teilweise ja
manche waren keine originalen
Produktgrößen manche schon eins ist auf
jeden Fall klar wir bekommen was für
unser Geld wir werden nicht über den
Tisch gezogen aber wenn ich jetzt die
Produktinformation lese 24 ausgefallene
und Beauty Produkte für Naschkatzen und
Beauty Fans Naschkatzen
und Beauty Fans vier Produkte also zwei
Make-up Produkte und zwei Pflegeprodukte
ich will jetzt eher sagen das ist ein
nasch obwohl ne wir haben noch den lash
Curler okay jetzt haben wir fünf
Produkte die in Beauty Richtung gehen
es tut mir so leid weil ich finde die
Daniela Katzenbergers mit ganz nette
tolle Person bestimmt ich kann sie
leider nicht so gut aber ich finde keine
Nachricht ich denke er macht Sinn wenn
man Daniela Katzenberger Fan ist und sie
unterstützen möchtet ich weiß auf jeden
Fall dass man nicht das große Geld jetzt
mit so einem Adventskalender macht das
ist irgendwie auch irgendwie so nices
Projekt einfach dass man so hat aber ich
finde es einfach so bezeichnet dass wenn
sie wirklich so eine eigene Schokolade
dann hat eigene Schokolade dass sie mit
Milch ist und das alles andere sind halt
diese richtig typischen bioveganen
organic Produkte
ja ich sehe in diesem Kalender nicht so
wirklich ihren Charakter ihre
Persönlichkeit irgendwie was dahin so
richtig so ja das ist ein Daniela
Katzenberger Adventskalender so wenn ich
jetzt nicht wüsste dass es Daniela
Katzenberger ist dann würde ich den
aufmachen und würde sagen ja okay das
ist halt so ein Veganer jetzt außer die
Schokolade Veganer Kalender einfach
außer dass eine Produkt was wirklich
ihren Namen drauf hat was nicht vegan
ist könnt ihr ja in den Kommentaren
weiter drüber debattieren wir sehen uns
dann das nächste Mal wieder bis dann
tschüssi
schnell ausmachen